Transcriber: Gözde Caymazer
Gözden geçirme: Erman Turkmen
İzzet Pinto
Televizyon Gurusu
Ben yaklaşık 10 yıldır
televizyon sektöründeyim.
Fakat 10 yıl önce ben ayakkabıcıydım.
Evet insanlar bayağı bir şaşırıyor.
Hani ayakkabı ne alaka yani?
Diziyle ayakkabı arasında
ne alaka olabilir ki?
En çok da buna yabancılar
şaşırıyor tabii ki.
Bana genelde "What is your
background?" diye soruyorlar.
İşte geçmişin nedir? Ben de
"shoe business" diyorum.
"Oo show business mı" diyorlar.
"No. Shoe business."
Hatta birisi bir keresinde
sarhoş musun demişti.
O kadar şaşırmışlardı.
Fakat bana göre ayakkabı satmakla
dizi satmak arasında hiçbir fark yok.
Ne yazık ki yıllarca küçüklüğümden beri
herkes bana hayalperest olduğumu söyledi.
Başarılı olacağıma hiç inanmadılar.
Bütün düşüncelerime
çok saçma gözüyle bakıyorlardı.
Ve hiçbir zaman başarılı
olamazsın diyorlardı.
Ben de buna bir anlam veremiyordum.
Çünkü bana göre hayalperest kişi
ayağı yere basmayan saçma
fikirleri olan insanlardır.
En önemlisi adım atmayan insanlardır.
Ben ise evet sürekli hayal kuruyordum
ama hep adım atıyordum.
Sonunda başarısız olduğum
için birçok zaman
herkes benim hayalperest
olduğumu düşündü.
17 yaşında ticaret hayatına atıldım.
Çok genç bir yaşta.
12 yıl boyunca 20 farklı iş denedim.
Hepsinde de başarısız oldum.
Ama yılmadım. Çünkü yılma lüksüm
yoktu. Yılsam ne olacaktı ki?
Hayal ettiğim bir hayat vardı ve
ben o hayata ulaşmak istiyordum.
O yüzden yılmadan sürekli bir iş denedim.
Bazen 1 ay, bazen 2 ay, bazen 1 sene.
Olmadığı zaman yeni bir işe geçiyordum.
Ama 20 denemeden sonra benim
hayatımı değiştirecek şey oldu.
Derler ya "Bir kitap okudum
ve hayatım değişti."
Aynen bana da öyle bir şey oldu.
Bir gün kuzenim kendi
hayatı ile ilgili bir kitap yazdı.
Reenkarnasyon ile ilgili.
Adı "Ben 44 Yaşındayım, Oğlum 53".
Ben de sırf kuzenime ayıp olmasın diye
kitabı gittim aldım, okudum.
Çünkü büyük ihtimalle bana
soracaktı "Nasıl buldun kitabımı?" diye.
Ben de o sormadan alayım okuyayım dedim.
Kitabı bitirdiğimde o kadar beğendim ki
hemen telefon açtım ona ve dedim ki
"Seni bütün dünyaya açacağım.
Seni bir dünya starı yapacağım."
O da "Deli misin, sen
ayakkabıcı değil misin?" dedi.
(Gülüşmeler)
Ben de "Merak etme, ben
bunu da satarım." dedim.
(Alkış)
Sağ olun.
Dedim ki "Sen bana özetini yaz."
Özete de sinopsis denirmiş.
Sinopsis dendiğini bile bilmiyordum.
İlk defa öğrendim böyle bir kelimeyi.
Hatta onu aradığımda dedim ki
"Bak o kadar ünlü olacaksın ki
yurtdışında imza günleri düzenleyecekler."
Tam deli olduğumu sandı tabii ki.
Neyse o da beni kırmamak
için bir özet yazdı.
Hemen internette araştırdım
acaba bu işin bir fuarı var mı,
nasıl bunu satabilirim diye.
Bir baktım, bir ay sonra
New York'da kitap fuarı varmış.
Dünya'nın en büyük kitap fuarı.
Benim de biriktirdiğim 1000 dolarım vardı.
Hemen 500 doları ile iki aktarmalı
New York bileti aldım. En ucuz biletten.
Bir de tek yıldızlı bir
otelde yerimi ayırttım.
Fuara gittim. Bütün
yayınevlerini gezdim.
Tayvan'da ki en büyük
yayınevini ikna ettim.
Kitabı Çince'ye çevirmeye karar verdiler
ve kitap Çince basıldı.
İşin güzeli basıldıktan bir hafta sonra
kitap en çok satanlar listesinde
dört numaraya ulaştı.
(Alkış)
Yani düşünün o zaman
Orhan Pamuk bile piyasada yok.
Ama kuzenim Tayvan'da bir star olmuş.
Yani çok heyecan vericiydi.
Sonra bu gazla Tayland'daki
yayınevlerini ikna etmeye çalıştım.
Onlar kitabı aldılar. Dedim ki "Niye
imza günü yapmıyorsunuz?
Bizi getirin." dedim.
Ve gerçekten de oldu.
Biz imza gününe gittik. Basından 100 kişi,
herkes çığlık atıyor, herkes imza istiyor.
Orada hatırlıyorum,
kuzenim neredeyse bayılacaktı.
Fakat ben ilk günden ona söylemiştim.
"Baha hatırlıyor musun?" dedim
"İlk gün seni aradığımda imza
günün olacağını söylemiştim."
Çünkü şöyle düşünüyorum. Eğer bir şeye
yüzde yüz inanırsanız illa ki olur.
İşimi çok sevmiştim. Yazar ajansıydım,
çok prestijli bir iş.
Ondan sonra yeni kitaplar
aramaya başladım.
Başka acaba hangi yazarlarla
çalışırım diye düşünmeye başladım.
Herkes Solmaz Kamuran'ın Kiraze adlı
romanından bahsediyordu.
Bende bakayım dedim. Kitapçıya
bir gittim kitap 350 sayfa.
Hayatta okumam dedim. Şimdi bana
vermez boşu boşuna okumayayım.
Ve randevu aldım görüşmeye gittim.
O kadar utandım ki
yani kitap hakkında konuşuyoruz ama
ben hiçbir şey bilmiyorum yani
özetini bile bilmiyorum.
"Hangi bölümü en çok beğendin?" diyor.
"Hepsi çok güzel." diyorum yani,
"Bütün kitabı çok çok beğendim" diyorum
ve çaktırmamaya çalışıyorum.
Yani düşünsenize bir edebiyatçının
karşısındasınız ve öğrenirse
kapıya koyar yani, imkânsız.
Rahmetli Çetin Altan yanımdaydı,
dedi ki "İzzet bunu kesin satar." dedi.
Sonradan da bana şunu sordu:
"Benim yayınevim beş yıl boyunca
satamadı, sen nasıl satacaksın?"
"Merak etmeyin. Çok iyi
bir kitabınız var." dedim.
Yani inanıyordum, herkes
öyle olduğunu söylüyordu.
Satarım dedim. Ve kitabı aldım ve
bir yılda sekiz ülkede yayına girdi.
Gerçekten bayağı bir başarılı oldu.
Yani işin kötüsü bu videoyu
izleyince öğrenecek o kitabı okumadığımı.
(Gülüşmeler)
Sonra Ayşe Kulin'le herkes
çalışmamı önerdi.
Randevu aldım tabii ki kitabını
okumadan gittim ona da.
Ama onu da ikna ettim.
Hemen yarım saatte anlaştık.
İmzalar atıldı.
Onun da kitaplarını satmaya başladım.
İşimi gerçekten çok seviyordum.
Fakat şöyle bir sıkıntı vardı.
Çeviri masrafları o kadar çoktu ki.
İşte editör, bu kitapların basılıp
bütün dünyaya yollanması.
Yani bütün masrafa gidiyordu kârım.
O yüzden ne kadar işimi sevsem
bile bırakmak zorundaydım.
Çünkü bir türlü para kazanamıyordum
ve işi bıraktım.
Düşündüm acaba başka ne iş yapsam diye.
Tarkan albüm çıkarttı. İngilizce albüm.
Ben müzik işine gireyim dedim.
(Gülüşmeler)
Sonuçta yani yurtdışına bir
şeyler satmayı seviyorum.
Hemen menajerinden
randevu aldım, gittim.
Daha önce Uzak Doğu’da yaşadığım için
oranın tarzına çok uyacağını düşündüm.
Ve bunları açıkladım.
Onunla da hemen anlaştık.
Fakat sonrasında yüzdede anlaşamadık.
Ben çok daha fazla bir yüzde istedim.
Onlar da Tarkan diye
tabii ki vermek istemedi.
Ben de o zaman çalışmam
dedim ve vazgeçtim.
Yani müzik işine de
iki günlüğüne girmiş oldum.
Ve ne yazık ki dönüp dolaşıp
ayakkabı işine geri döndüm.
Çok çok mutsuzdum.
Sultanahmet’in orada
Gedik Paşa’da dükkânımız vardı.
İşte Ruslara İranlılara
ayakkabı satıyorduk.
Ondan sonra ben Mecidiyeköy'deki
dükkânları geziyordum,
sipariş almaya çalışıyordum.
Çok çok büyük bir
hayal kırıklığı yaşadım.
Çünkü yani 20 tane iş
denedim ve hiçbirisi olmadı.
Ama yapacak bir şey yoktu.
Ama müthiş bir şey oldu.
Yazar kuzenimin kızı bir gün beni aradı.
Dedi ki yurtdışına
niye format satmıyorsun?
Bende "Format nedir?" diye sordum.
Yarışma programlarına format denirmiş.
Mutlaka satarsın. Annemin kitabını
sattıysan kesin format da satarsın dedi.
(Gülüşmeler)
Ve tamam dedim bari hani 21. iş olsun.
En kötüsü bu da tutmayacak.
Ve o zamanlar bir gelin kaynana
programı vardı, inanılmaz meşhurdu.
Bu Semra kaynana ile ünlenen.
Beni o formatın yazarı ile tanıştırdılar.
Murat Üçkardeşler.
Sağ olsun o da hemen güvendi,
bana formatını verdi.
Hemen yine interneti araştırdım.
Google’a girdim yani bu iş
nasıl olur diye nasıl satılır diye.
Cannes’da bunun fuarı varmış.
Televizyonculuk fuarı varmış.
Hemen aradım fuarı "Stand
kiralayabilir miyim?" dedim.
Hiç unutmuyorum en küçük stand
10 metrekare stand 10.500 Euro.
Ama benim sadece 500 Eurom vardı.
10.000 Euro'ya ihtiyacım vardı.
Şimdi kimseden de borç almak
istemiyorum, çünkü her işi batırdım yani,
büyük ihtimalle bu iş de batacaktı.
O yüzden farklı işlerden tanıdığım
reklam ajansı sahibi arkadaşım vardı
Levent Özdemir. Ona gittim.
Projeyi anlattım, çok saçma buldu.
(Gülüşmeler)
Dedim ki ne olur bana 10.000 Euro ver.
Ama tutarsa 3 ay sonra
sana 20.000 vereceğim.
Ama tutmazsa çöp dedim. Yani bu bir kumar.
O da sağ olsun aslında
durumu çok iyi değildi.
Sırf destek olmak için
bana 10.000 Euro verdi.
Çok heyecanlandım.
Beş dakikada 10.000 Euro yaptım,
"Ne kadar kolaymış para kazanmak." dedim.
Yani yıllarca kazanamadım,
beş dakikada 10.000 Eurom oldu.
Tam fuara gidecekken babam yanıma geldi
dedi ki “Bak oğlum sen çok çalışkansın,
çok yaratıcısın ama inanılmaz şanssız bir
çocuksun. Bence en iyisi ablana
%5 ortaklık ver,
sana şans getirsin.” dedi.
Ben de tamam bir de bunu deneyeyim,
belki de sorun bendedir dedim.
Ve ablamla beraber fuara gittik.
Gittik bir baktık fuarın en küçük en
çirkin standı bizim. Tuvaletin yanında.
Ve Lübnanlı bir müşteri geldi,
projeyi almak istediğini söyledi.
Fakat adam bana güvenmedi.
Yani ilk defa katılmıştım,
söylediği hiçbir şeyi anlamıyordum.
Hiçbir sektörle ilgili
terimi bilmiyordum.
Adam dedi ki ben seni Türkiye’de
ziyaret edeceğim o zaman imzalarız dedi.
Fakat işin kötüsü Türkiye’de benim
ofisim yok, ayakkabı dükkânım var.
Yani düşünsenize adamı ayakkabı dükkânına
çağırsam adam kamera şakası zannedecek.
Kesin imzalamayacak. Levent’i aradım.
Dedim ki yardımına ihtiyacım var yine.
Senin ofisini kullanmam lazım dedim.
O da kabul etti. Hemen kendime bir
tabela yaptırdım böyle Global Agency diye.
(Gülüşmeler)
Ondan sonra söktüm onun tabelasını,
kendi tabelamı taktım.
Ekibine gittim dedim ki çaktırmayın bundan
sonra benim için çalışıyorsunuz dedim.
Sakın çaktırmayın müşterim gelecek.
Ve müşteri geldi. Çok güzel geçti.
Ben uzun süre mecburen
Levent’in ofisini kullandım.
İşte klasik müşteri gelmeden önce tabelayı
çıkartıyordum, kendi tabelamı takıyordum.
Ve artık yapımcılar beni
öğrenmeye başlamıştı.
İşte kanallar beni arıyordu.
Bir gün telefonu bir açtım,
karşımdaki şunu sordu.
"İzzet beyin sekreteri ile
görüşebilir miyim?"
Yani şimdi benim sekreterim
yok ki şirketimin sekreteri olsun,
bir de yani imkânsız.
O yüzden dedim ki sen
beş dakika sonra ara dedim.
Hemen birisini buldum, dedim ki
çaldığı zaman sen aç bana bağlarsın.
Yani madem imaj bu kadar önemli.
(Alkış)
İşte bu şekilde gittik.
İşlerim iyi gidiyordu.
Hayalimdeki arabayı aldım.
Böyle üstü açık bir araba.
Ağustos’ta bile 40 derece sıcakta
hep üstünü açardım.
Bayağı bir terlerdim.
Ama hep yani otobüse
binmekten sıkılmıştım yani.
Ve bir gün bir baktım yanımdan
eski bir arkadaşım geçiyor,
hep bana hayalperest diyen.
Hemen kornaya bastım,
camı indirdim, bir selam verdim.
Tabii ki oradaki mesaj şuydu, bak ben
hayalperest değilmişim, sen yanılmışsın.
Bu format işi çok iyi gitmeye başladı.
Lübnanlı müşterim bir gün aradı.
Dedi ki bana "Türkiye’den
dizi bulur musun?"
Ben de "Dizi mi?
Kim Türk dizisi alır" dedim.
Yani çok saçma geldi,
ben bile izlemiyordum.
Kim izleyecek dedim yani.
Çok lokal olduğunu düşünüyordum.
Ama sonuçta adam müşterimdi.
Mecburen araştırmak zorundaydım.
İşte birkaç haftamı verdim hep küfrederek.
Müşterilere gittim böyle DVD topluyorum.
Adama mesaj attım
"DVD'lerin elimde." diye.
Adam cevap vermiyor.
Arıyorum telefonlarımı açmıyor.
Ben de masanın üstüne koydum.
Üç ay masamın üstünde bu DVD'ler durdu.
Bir gün Bulgar müşterim aradı.
Dedi ki "Bana Türkiye’den birkaç
yapımcının telefonunu verir misin?"
Soracağım yani ellerinde
bir şey var mı?
Bende var, sana yollayayım dedim.
Masamın üstünde bir sürü
DVD vardı. Hepsini yolladım.
İçinde de Binbir Gece’nin DVD'si varmış,
haberim bile yok hayatta seyretmemişim.
Ve bunu almaya karar verdiler.
Bir yayınladılar, kanalın
reytinglerini dört katına çıkardı.
Ve kanal 4. Kanal dan 1. Kanal oldu.
Vay be dedim elimde
elmas varmış haberim yok.
Ve bu başarıyı kullanarak 60 ülkeyi
ikna ettim ve 60 ülkeye dizi sattım.
Ve aslında bu Binbir Gece sayesinde
bu Türk dizi ihracatı patladı.
Ve gerçekten büyük bir tesadüf
yani masamda duruyormuş.
Bulgaristan aldı sonra dünyaya satıldı.
Yani düşünün yani Kolombiya’dan
tutun Vietnam’a, Güney Amerika,
herkes bu işe âşık ve
büyük piyango oldu bana.
Tam o sıralar Muhteşem Yüzyıl
dizisi yayına girdi.
Ben de yapımcısını tanıyorum Timur Savcı.
Daha önce filmlerini temsil etmiştim,
arkadaş olmuştuk, düğünüme bile gelmişti.
Kesin bana verir dedim, zaten arkadaşız.
Gittim kesinlikle vermeyi düşünmüyor.
Ama benim de en büyük hayalim
Muhteşem Yüzyıl’ı almak,
yani hani takıntı hâline getirdim.
İkinci kere gittim yine vermedi.
Ve en sonunda beşincide verdi.
O kadar mutlu oldum ki
heyecandan kendimi kaybettim.
Ve dedim ki bütün standımı
üç katına çıkaracağım.
Cannes’daki bütün billboardları
senin için alacağım,
her dergiye beş sayfa
dergi ilanı vereceğim.
Bütün oyuncuları getirip
1000 kişilik parti yapacağım,
şarkıcı Amerika’dan getirteceğim.
Yani kendimden geçtim gerçekten.
O kadar heyecanlandım ki
bir sürü söz verdim.
Ve oradan çıktıktan sonra ne yaptığımın
farkına vardım ve yani resmen
milyon dolarlık reklam sözü verdim.
Ama bir kere söz vermiştim.
Sonuçta bu diziyi bana vermişti
ve yapmak zorundaydım.
Ve dediklerimin hepsini yaptım.
İlk defa bir Türk dizisi için
dünya lansmanı yapıldı.
Bütün oyuncular geldi, Halit Ergenç’ten
tutun Meryem Uzerli’ye.
Kırmızı halıda yürüdüler ve
aylarca herkes bu partiyi konuştu.
Bu fuar bittikten sonra yurt dışında
çalışan bir elemanım vardı
ve bana bir e-mail yolladı.
Dedi ki “Ayın 12’si oldu, galiba
maaşımı yollamayı unuttunuz.”
İşin kötüsü unutmamıştım, param bitmişti.
Yani resmen banka hesabım sıfırlanmıştı.
Ama bir kere söz vermiştim ve
bunu yapmak zorundaydım.
Ama iyi ki de yapmışım.
Çünkü bu diziyi 75 ülkeye sattık.
Tam 300 milyon kişi izliyor.
(Alkış)
Yani hayatta risk
almazsanız kazanamazsınız.
Ben hayatım boyunca risk
aldım ve iyi ki de almışım.
Çünkü bu sayede bir yerlere geldim.
Ve bu Türk dizileri sayesinde tabii ki
Türkiye'nin ihracatı da çok büyüdü.
Bizim şirketimizin ihracatı çok büyüdü.
Bir tek Muhteşem Yüzyıl değil,
bütün Türk dizileri sayesinde.
Ve bu dizilerden çok
fazla kişi ekmek yiyor.
Yani hiç aklınıza gelmeyecek
kişiler ekmek yiyor.
Mesela Şili’de bir tane striptizci var.
Bu adam haftada bir evlere gidiyormuş.
Ancak iş buluyormuş.
100 dolara çalışıyormuş.
Sonra bir baktı, bir sürü teklif gelmeye
başladı. Yani birden kapalı gişe oldu.
Bunun nedeni de ülkede Binbir Gece
dizisi yayınlanmaya başladı.
Ve şansa adam Halit Ergenç’in ikizi çıktı.
(Gülüşmeler)
Yani bu sayede kapalı gişe oldu o adam.
Ve fiyatını 250 dolara çıkartmış bu şeyde.
Bütün haberlere falan çıktı.
Bir de çok şanslı Muhteşem Yüzyıl
dizisi yayına girdi.
Ve fiyatını tam 400 dolar yapmış.
(Gülüşmeler)
Çünkü evlere Binbir Gecede'ki
Onur karakteri ile giriyor,
böyle takım elbiseli, sonra
Sultan Süleyman olarak çıkıyor.
(Alkış)
Yani ben de hep diyorum yani
bize de bir pay verse iyi olur,
yani sayemizde çok iyi kazanıyor.
Fakat baktığınız zaman her şey bir proje,
10.000 Euro borçla başlamıştı.
Fakat en önemlisi bir
büyük hayalle başladı.
O da başarma hayali.
Ve ben yıllar önce şunu fark ettim.
Aslında ben babam için
başarmak istiyormuşum.
Çünkü küçüklüğümden beri beni
yetiştirmek için o kadar uğraştı ki.
Hiç unutmuyorum bir gün sekiz yaşındaydım.
Yazları Büyük Ada'ya giderdik.
Bir gün eve geldi dedi ki senin artık
para kazanma vaktin geldi dedi.
Ben de para mı kazanacağım?
Sekiz yaşındayım ben,
hani niye para kazanacağım dedim.
Yok artık para kazanmayı
öğrenmen lazım dedi.
O zamanlar saat sektöründeydi,
yurtdışından saat ithal ederdi.
Dedi ki “Sana bu saatleri vereceğim,
Perşembe günleri pazarda satacaksın.”
Benim için imkânsız bir şey.
Çünkü biliyorsunuz pazarda
satmak için bağırmak lazım
5 lira 10 lira gelin işte saat var diye.
Ben de utangaç bir çocuktum,
o yüzden imkânsızdı.
Hemen bir arkadaşıma gittim. Dedim ki bak
sen bağıracaksın ben satacağım dedim.
(Gülüşmeler)
Ve böyle birkaç saatte
biz bütün saatleri bitirdik.
Daha sonra büyük bir heyecanla parayı
aldık eve geldik babamı bekliyoruz.
Babam geldiği zaman bakın çocuklar dedi.
İşte diyelim bugünün
parası ile 100 lira kazandık.
Bu 100 liranın 50 lirası
maliyet, 50 lirası kâr.
Alın size 25’er lira dedi.
Ben çok kızdım.
Baba niye ona 25 veriyorsun?
Ona 10 lira ver,
bana 40 lira ver ben senin oğlunum dedim.
Yok oğlum dedi. Bak dedi eğer hayatta
paylaşmayı bilmezsen kazanamazsın.
Ve düşünsenize ben bu
dersi sekiz yaşımda aldım.
Ve hâlâ geçerli.
(Alkış)
Eğer hayatta paylaşmayı
bilmezseniz kazanamazsınız.
O zamandan sonra ticareti çok sevdim.
Çünkü küçük yaşta beni yetiştirmişti.
Ve 17 yaşında üniversiteyi
Amerika’da kazandım.
Fakat ticareti o kadar sevmiştim
ki gitmek istemedim.
Babama dedim ki eğer izin verirsen
ben okumak istemiyorum
ve ticarete atılmak istiyorum dedim.
19 yaşımda Uzak Doğu’ya yerleşmeye
karar verdim ve Uzak Doğu'ya gittim.
Onun en büyük hayali
benim başardığımı görmekti.
Çünkü herkese ispat etmek istiyordu.
Bizim gittiğimiz yol farklı bir yol.
Ama yanlış bir yol değildi,
sadece farklı bir yoldu.
Ve insanlara bunu
ispat etmek istiyordu.
Ve ne yazık ki bir gün kötü
bir hastalığa yakalandı.
Fakat yanıma geldi dedi ki senin
başarılı olduğunu görmeden
bu hayattan gitmeyeceğim dedi
ve bunun için yemin etti.
Fakat ben başarısız
oldukça o daha da ezildi.
Bir gün JCI tarafından,
bu işlere yeni girmiştim.
Bana Yılın Girişimcisi ödülünü verdiler.
İnanılmaz mutlu oldum.
Ödül törenine gittim.
Babam hastanede olduğu
için ödül törenine gelemedi.
Ve ödülümü aldıktan sonra koşa koşa
hastaneye gittim ve bu ödülü ona verdim.
Çünkü onun sayesinde bu ödülü almıştım.
Ve çok yazıktır ki ödülü verdikten
birkaç gün sonra vefat etti.
Ve şöyle düşünüyorum,
sanki bu ödülü bekliyormuş.
Yani hayatı boyunca bu ödülü bekledi
ve ona hediye edebildim.
O hayatta iken bu ödülü ona
verebildiğim için inanılmaz mutluyum.
Ve eminim bugünde burada
olsaydı benimle gurur duyardı.
Hikâyemi dinlediğiniz
için teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)